well I can guarantee you this video will
get blocked in China I want to let you
know that this video is sponsored by the
podcast radio versus the Martians it is
a nerdy geeky podcast hosted by Mike
Gillis and Casey Dorne with a revolving
stable of guests they talk about
everything from sci-fi to fantasy comic
books movies and of course the Oubre of
arnold schwarzenegger they are funny
their insightful they're worth listen so
go check them out at Radio versus
Martians calm or wherever you get your
podcasts so folks it is that time and
I'm gonna be talking about an issue
related to lgbtq+
representation which does mean that I'm
gonna switch things out here just a
little bit so this one is a little bit
different because it's less about
representation directly than it is about
something that I often hear brought up
in relation to why representation is not
more prevalent and that is the Chinese
box office for the release of any given
film this is brought up a whole lot when
I talk about representation in
mainstream films which is generally what
I talk about when I talk about
representation cuz back that's where I
want to see it so I talked about things
like Harry Potter Star Wars the MCU it
is inevitable that's somewhere along the
line somebody or usually several
somebodies is gonna end up saying well
you know they can't because then the
film would not be able to be played in
China and they need that market and the
thing was I had kind of I just kind of
assumed a truth in that cuz it makes
logical sense certainly but then a news
story broke that did get a ton of press
but I caught it and it made me go wait a
minute
and then I started actually digging into
the reality
of Chinese distribution for American
blockbusters and I'm realizing that this
argument for why we can't have lgbtq+
representation in mainstream films
doesn't really hold up so we got a few
things to kind of cover here the first
is the Chinese market
size-wise in terms of raw numbers raw
box office numbers it's pretty big yeah
obviously China is a big country there's
a lot of people in it that's a lot of
potential tickets to sell here's the
first thing you need to realize though
international markets of any kind the
the u.s. distributor the maker of the
film they do not make as much money on
international distribution the exact
numbers are honestly hard to nail down
because while Hollywood fudge is the
crap out of their books anyways so it's
really hard to know for certain but
standard rule of thumb metric is that
the what the the studio behind the film
in the US gets roughly again it'll vary
from place to place but they get roughly
half the box-office take in the US and
they get roughly a quarter of the
box-office take for international that
varies territory by territory it can
vary film by film sometimes different
deals are negotiated but that's the
general rule of industry rule of thumb
so the first thing you need to realize
is if a movie on paper made as much
internationally as it made in the US
it's still only made about half as much
internationally for the studio that's
making the thing in the first place so
that's the first thing to take into
consideration so even though there are
films where the Chinese market was very
big and like the Chinese market matters
so don't let what I just said make you
go oh well it doesn't matter well of
course it matters but it matters in the
sense of icing it's real
really hard for a for a tentpole film an
expensive blockbuster film to fail
domestically and then make enough
internationally to get a sequel I think
the quintessential
example right now is warcraft Warcraft
bombed in the u.s. is one of the only
films to make over a hundred million
dollars in China when it couldn't break
that in the US and there was some
thought for a little while because that
film actually even had some Chinese
companies involved in the financing
that's an element I'll get into in a
minute that maybe there would still be a
sequel in possibly even more tailored to
the Chinese market last word on that
from director Duncan Jones is that it
really doesn't look like it's gonna
happen so even a film that by far made
more money in China again raw box office
take not necessarily cut to the studio
that made it couldn't get a sequel now
have there been times where it like just
nudged it over yes Pacific Rim but even
there that was just barely and they cut
the budget of the sequel by 40 million
dollars from the first one to the second
one and jet and realize we live in a
world these days where sequels get
bigger budgets than their predecessors
so to come out with the second one on
the strength of well you know the the
American box office wasn't awful but the
first Pacific room was expensive so when
the domestic didn't quite get it there
the international just really pushed it
over but like it's now toast cuz
uprising did not make what it needed to
but Chinese markets Studios don't make
their profit they don't get into the
black on the Chinese market they they
pad their profit with the Chinese market
but they kind of need to pretty much get
to profitability in the US so that the
international market can be icing
because the international market by
itself doesn't make a film profitable
for a US tentpole majors mainstream
blockbuster type film so that's the
first thing so
the next thing to talk about is what
actually gets censored in China because
unlike the US where we use words like
censorship for basically any time
there's some sort of protest to say like
hey we think this is a bad idea or it's
bad representation of this people will
claim I'm being censored or they say
they're being censored because somebody
deletes their comments off a YouTube
video like that's China has capital C
government censorship so they do
actually do that now what kind of things
do they censor films for well it
actually runs the gamut and some of them
make some degree of sense some of them
are really weird so like I've got some
notes so if you'll pardon me so some of
the reasons that some some films have
been banned and not been allowed to be
shown in China include here's what you'd
expect
unflattering depictions of the Chinese
government and that can very often come
up if a film deals with Tibet and the
acquisition of Tibet by China they don't
like that at all so anything that deals
with that probably not gonna show up and
again as far as you know if the
government is controlling the
entertainment and the information that
comes in yeah you'd expect them to block
that but they also they they prevent the
distribution of films with live-action
talking animals depicts depicting time
travel and Winnie the Pooh that last one
because the current president of China
has been unflatteringly compared to
Winnie the Pooh on Chinese social media
and so out of spite
they they blocked the recent Disney film
Christopher Robin from being released in
China just because of those jokes so for
a reason that had nothing to do with the
film that's the level of censorship in
China they can do it for whatever reason
they want they don't have to have a
rational justification they don't have
to answer to anybody for this they'll
give a reason but they don't have to
defend it they just get to say here's
why and not let it in so the banning of
in the Chinese market definitely does
happen so again it's totally logical
that even though the Chinese market
maybe won't be what completely saves a
film or makes it like really truly
profitable but is still a substantial
market and knowing that they will ban
for certain content which does include
sexual depictions a both straight and
gay explicit sexual content they will
ban although they're much more likely to
ban even implied sexual content when it
comes to LGBTQ and gay characterization
so logically you would go oh well
Studios aren't gonna put that in because
they you know would they want to get in
the Chinese market and otherwise it
won't get there that's logical point
though lots of films with stuff that
would get material banned in China does
get released there because they have a
different cut that gets released in
China basically the way the times at
which something gets outright banned is
when the reason it's getting banned is
so intrinsic to the plot that you can't
actually remove it and still have a
functional narrative so like Brokeback
Mountain you can't remove the gay
content from Brokeback Mountain you
literally have no movie at that point I
mentioned time-travel I don't know
exactly why China's got a bug up its
butt about that but you know the the
Back to the Future never got released
there because you can't take the time
travel a lot of back to the future it's
the entire premise but here's some stuff
that has been removed so Titanic Kate
Winslet's breasts removed for the
Chinese release and released to the
Chinese market Mission Impossible three
something as petty as underwear hanging
on a clothesline that got removed Casino
Royale removed a Cold War reference
pirates at World's End cut about half of
chow yun-fat screen time out of concerns
that he that it was a negative portrayal
of
Chinese character Cloud Atlas 38 minutes
worth of sexual content both straight
and gay that's about 20% of a film but
they still cut it in released it in
China Iron Man 3 actually added material
in four minutes of Chinese specific
scenes including some product placement
for regional products as well as a
Chinese doctor character alien covenant
were moved to the gay kiss between two
male Androids and here is the one that
when I read this story made me made my
brain stop and go wait a minute
bohemian rhapsody' just got released to
China they managed to cut and they only
had to cut it would think it was a less
than four minutes worth of material to
remove the explicit acknowledgments of
Freddie Mercury as that he was not
straight now does that mean the movie
does not make some degree of sense and
is worse oh yeah oh yeah because like
the most notable thing is do you remove
the coming-out scene that he has to
marry and suddenly them breaking up
comes out of nowhere it makes no sense
and has no context because that's the
reason they broke up so the let me in
first thing I'll is that these cuts I'm
not saying that these cuts and the film
was released in China and it's just as
good of course it's not they're worse
for it because those things are on the
movie for a reason in the first place
here's my point though the artistic
integrity of these films is not the
concern the concern if if they can get
away with cutting it they will and the
kinds of things that you would put in to
a film like Harry Potter which by the
way the books of Harry Potter are banned
but the films aren't figure that one out
things like Harry Potter like Star Wars
like the MCU the actual acknowledgments
that we would expect to get that you
know that's at least someone like me
personally
asking for at this point because like
I've said this before actual stories
built around the you know being an LGBTQ
he was person or lgbtq+ relationships I
actually don't have a ton of interest in
because I don't really like romance and
like realistic life drama stories they
don't interest me
so getting representation the kind of
films I want which would be things like
the MCU and Star Wars and Harry Potter
would just need like a line or two a
line or two that for the Chinese market
you can cut or dub over and I know you
can
cuz you do it regularly so unless a film
is actually being co-financed by a
Chinese company because that does happen
so like some examples where that has
happened in the last few years the the
last two most recent Mission Impossible
movies transformers four pixels fast in
fury seven and eight and this one was
interesting
Star Trek beyond Star Trek beyond was
co-financed by a Chinese company and it
has an acknowledgement of Hikaru Sulu as
being married to a man that was in the
film partly made with Chinese money but
even if you say that that's a random
outlier like they snuck it past and the
Chinese people didn't notice it or
whatever which that's condescending to
assume that they couldn't pick up on
that but fine let's assume that for a
second unless you have a film that is
being directly financed by a Chinese
company or Chinese interests you
wouldn't remove any lgbtq+
representation at the development stage
you can still write it you can still
shoot it you can still have it in the
film released in territories where that
sort of thing is not a big deal so you
can give us lgbtq+ representation in the
States in Europe in all sorts of other
markets where that's not going to get
the film ban and
just remove it when you release the film
in places where it is banned and I don't
I can't say this for necessarily every
market that might conceivably ban it but
with China which is the biggest it's the
one people keep citing to me is the
reason we can't have this representation
in that one at least it's not they're
not actually taking a moral stance in
the sense of we will not financially
benefit a movie that depicts this they
just don't want it on their soil because
if it can be removed they'll still
release the movie so it's not like they
have a problem with having money go to a
studio that made something like this in
the first place they're not that level
of moralistic it's strictly a matter of
how they exert control within their own
borders so they just don't want it in
their cut they don't care if it's in the
u.s. cut if it's in the European cut
they don't care so and this is the other
thing that was funny to me because I've
like I said I've been hearing the
Chinese market you can't put LGBTQ
people in movies I've been hearing this
for a while when I actually stopped and
thought about it I couldn't think of an
instance where that was being cited by a
filmmaker by studio I was always hearing
this excuse in comments from I don't
fans defenders of the status quo The
Groundlings not the people who would
actually be making this decision and it
is now having looked into it fully sunk
in with me it's not a reality it's an
excuse it is a really logical excuse
it's a believable excuse which is why I
believed it too until I looked into it
and it just doesn't hold water so next
time somebody well in my comment section
certainly but I would say wherever
tries to make the claim that we can't
have gay people lesbians bisexuals
transgender people gender-fluid people
asexual people none of this gender or
sexual weirdness in our movies we can't
I mean it'd be nice but we can't cuz it
China next time somebody claims that
link them this video cuz they're wrong
they're making excuses it is so easy to
have a line confirming that a gay person
freakin exists and dub it over cut it
out you do it all the time Hollywood so
people throwing out this excuse to
defend them stop cuz it's not true the
Chinese market being a reason that we
can't have lgbtq+ representation sorry
hands tied we need that market don't
think so whatever your thoughts are on
this drop something down in the comments
let us talk about it talk about it
respectfully and if you feel like that
my conclusion is wrong that my numbers
are wrong please provide me with yours
and I will happily look at them and take
in the new information but this is what
I came up with when I actually looked at
numbers in reality and records of what
was censored and why but whatever your
thoughts are drop it down in the
comments and we will indeed talk about
it whole bunch of stuff to do down there
buttons links patreon be really
appreciated trying to get a few more
things off the ground and yeah it would
help but there's a whole bunch of other
links down there besides I wrote a book
guy you've got another channel that's
more about this whole end of my life um
so take a look at some of this stuff or
don't it's okay if you don't because at
the end of the day folks I mean you're
the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]